un vieux maîtres entourés de ses
domestiques
voilà le point de départ de la dernière
création d' hervé van der meulen la
maison dos écrit par roland dubillard
est une série de sketches qui parle de
mélancolie d'espoir d'angoise durant
deux heures 58 saynètes se succèdent
c'est une écriture que j'avais jamais
traité l'écriture de dubillard que je
trouve très fort très poétique vraiment
très belle parce que c'était la
possibilité de faire un spectacle de
troupes et qu'on fait toujours un
spectacle de troupes de studio
d'asnières en coproduction avec
montansier chaque année avec beaucoup de
d'acteurs sur de jeunes apprentis
comédiens issus du studio d'asnières le
seul centre de ce genre en france
sur scène ils sont 15 pour jouer pas
moins de 50 rôle certains personnages
non pas l'identité
il n'ya pas non plus de chronologie
précise c'est compliqué ces espèces de
puzzle voit comme une pièce qu'on va du
premier acte au cinquième rang et puis
voilà on suit la trame dans mature gîte
là c'est compliqué il n'ya pas vrai mais
bon il ya plein de petites actions qui
accumulait les unes sur les autres
donnent une grande action en résidence
au théâtre versailles et la troupe a
travaillé le texte est répétée durant
plusieurs semaines
métaphore du squelette humain la maison
de l'osm et en scène de l'humour noir de
l'absurde est un langage un peu creux
vous faites quoi l'émission devoir
[Musique]
d'utiliser certains mots effectivement
comme con comme merde comme ça mais ils
les utilisent au milieu d'un langage
extrêmement travaillé un peu à la
prévert un peu c'est une écriture qui
ressemble beaucoup c'est à celle de
raymond
aussi cette pièce est la quatrième
collaboration d'hervé van der meulen
avec le théâtre montansier sans doute la
dernière car le 30 juin prochain il
prendra sa retraite de la direction de
sa troupe
l'histoire de ce vieux monsieur de la
maison dos qui s'en va cayla sa maison
j'ai vu une espèce de blagues pour fêter
mon départ petite randonnée
il va falloir que je vois